morning dr. McConnell morning James this  whole process started with the Lazarus  serum the goal here is simple bring  someone back from the dead tell of you  let's make some history about 1/5  kilovolts perfect maybe for you  up the dosage max anything chuckle you  are playing God with a bunch of dead  animals if we're gonna be asking big  questions to be ready for the answers  that's too much neural activity what a  house we're gonna duplicate the  experiment three two one  so educated clear I'm gonna bring  someone back from the dead  this isn't some lab experiment this is  crossing a line this is a human kid  did I just die I went somewhere that was  a dream it was hell  you just forget remarks things in it's  like your body  subject is extremely aggressive I can't  predict how this will end please  you have no idea what you've done  you